[Music]
foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
hi there happy Tuesday I'm Rosanna
Lockwood coming up on uncensored tonight
the last Bastion of free speech the
feminist academic Kathleen stock finally
speaking at the Oxford Union despite
protests over her appearance there over
her alleged transphobic views now how
much did Holly Willoughby know new
pictures emerging or poly kissing the
cheek of Phillip schofield's young lover
at Norwood ceremy three years ago as ITV
faces further cover-up and our payoff
claims as well we're talking all about
that with talk TV host former culture
secretary Nadine Doris joining us live
and it is not just ITV facing rumors of
toxicity on set Channel 4 also
reportedly parting ways with escape to
the Chateau pair you may know them dick
and Angel and the BBC's Greg Wallace has
quit inside the factory for allegedly
offending women on set now we're going
to be asking TV institutionally toxic to
join us for that
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored with
Rosanna Lockwood well good evening
welcome to Piers Morgan and centered
does it need saying with me Rosanna
Lockwood not Piers Morgan in a lovely
red dress this evening now speaking of
which wanted to start show tonight with
a topic familiar to this show to Piers
Morgan as well something he asks fairly
regularly as we try to find the answer
to this the question with stumps
politicians as well at the moment what
is a woman and who is allowed to say
what a woman is now tonight I'm gonna
have this presented to you by a woman
and why are we going back here well a
talk is happening this evening at the
Oxford Union it's been going on for last
few hours or so it's a feminist
Professor involved who said quote it's
not hate speech to say that males cannot
be women hundreds protesting outside the
Oxford Union are causing her of accusing
her rather of being transphobic now a
protester even managed to glue
themselves to the floor of the Union
delaying the start of the event but that
hasn't deterred Professor stock who
believes All Views should be heard
you know a small number of people find
that very very controversial and then
most people I agree with you actually
don't if you don't hear from them so
often but I do think that most people
haven't gone crazy and they don't think
that just by declaring you're a woman a
man can become a woman
um whereas there are a small number of
people who really think that's heresy
well even the Prime Minister found
himself wading Into The Fray last night
saying this talk did need to go ahead
universities are places he said well
debates should be supported Rishi sunak
also adding quote we mustn't allow a
small but vocal few to shut down
discussion now that's really at the core
of all this isn't it the Hallmark of a
civil society respectful debate most
sensible people would probably agree
with that when we shut down debates we
are no better than dictatorships but the
problem is respect has disappeared from
a lot of conversation about gender in
recent years now
um I've lived all over the world and I
can say quite comfortably Britain as a
Brit it's a fairly mild country pretty
moderate when it comes to most things
and that's why extremism in any form
whether it be political religious
environmental or gender basis we're
talking about today it's just so
noticeable when it bubbles up isn't it
and and this trans conversation seems to
have gotten so far out of hand from
extremists on both both sides that I
find myself worried for those that are
caught in the crossfire and I think
those people are of course the members
of the trans Community who are trying to
get on with their lives some of whom
might not feel represented by what they
hear some might and also for the women
who feel their biological sex is
suddenly up for debate on top of Decades
of heart hard fought for rights now as a
woman I gotta be honest I don't actually
feel infringed upon by much of this on a
daily basis but I don't speak for all
women what I do find fascinating is that
it is some men who seem to feel most
aggrieved by this debate they're the
ones that are up in arms they're the
ones shouting the loudest for what they
see as an attack on us on women after a
lifetime of being a woman let me say
that's something I did not see coming
now let me say cool the debate a bit
it's a bit simplistic isn't it just me
saying that you know especially as a
biological woman straight Etc but where
do we go from here I do feel as with
most fights both sides are not really
listening to each other fully and as
with all flights we'll never arrive at a
pure solution to this issue so we do
have to learn to find this Middle Ground
to Coexist on this same patch of Earth
and to do so as peacefully as possible
let's see if it's possible for us to do
that now here on the show joining me to
debate this issue Dr Marie Carl the
Dowda one of more the 40 Oxford
academics who signed a letter supporting
this professor Kathleen stock this
evening and we're also joined by Dr Max
Morris Electra at Oxford Brooks
University who's been protesting against
tonight's speech at the Oxford Union
it's just great to have you both on
because you're right at the center of
this issue academics you're Associated
to this you both support either support
or against Kathleen stock this evening
let's come to you first Dr Marie because
you wrote a letter in support of
Kathleen stock talk to us about why you
felt it is in important for her to her
to be heard
was the purpose of the letter was to
show that people from very different
political or intellectual backgrounds
can be uh well can stand together in
defense of Kathleen Stock's right to
express her uh her thoughts about what
we mean by gender what we mean by sex I
have well I come from a background of
gender studies and having read her book
I was impressed by how how mild and
measured her approach is contrary to
what is often said Catherine stock has
no such thing as transphobic attitude
towards trans people she does
think that there is such a a thing as
well not feeling that you belong in the
right body she does believe in people's
rights to live their life as well be
belonging to the other gender she also
happens to believe that the material
reality the biological reality of
women's bodies do put them at some
certain risks and that so much as policy
making has to aim for a middle ground
for something that is accommodating for
everyone there is such a problem as what
we do of safeguarding policies where
there is a need to provide very clear
boundaries that are meant to defend the
most vulnerable the more the most at
risk and her view is in fact much more
well much milder than if you have many
other gender critical feminists
there are I mean when you talk about
vulnerable groups at risk women do fall
into that category but trans people do
as well let's let's come over to Dr Max
on that because uh Dr Marie was just
saying Dr Max that when we talk about
Kathleen this woman who's given the
speech this evening at the Oxford Union
her views are moderate and mild and yet
if you were to see some of the activism
or what's being said about her it seems
that she's been described as a
transphobe and a Turf um talk to us
about your impression of the speech
so I think that one of the issues in
this discussion is that we're all
talking about Professor stock who
actually isn't an expert in gender or
sexuality studies she's a professor of
philosophy but my perspective on this is
that there are far more qualified voices
that we should be hearing in this
discussion there are professors who have
been exploring questions around gender
and trans identity and inclusion for
decades and they haven't just waded into
this discussion to sell their latest
book so yes I joined protesters today
outside the Oxford Union my protest sign
said
as you can see let's platform trans
professors because we're hearing too
much about trans people but not from
trans people themselves so we really
need to have more trans and non-binary
voices as a part of this discussion
rather than just uh you know any old
Professor who wants to flog a book
wading into the debate I mean Dr Marie
that sounds like a fair argument when
speaking about trans rights and trans
people you should have trans voices this
wasn't a debate this evening and but I
want to give you an opportunity to come
back to Dr Mack saying that that
Kathleen's stock shouldn't be at the
center of this debate and isn't an
expert in gender well I think Kathleen
stock would entirely agree with the fact
that she should not be at the center of
this debate this is a very long
discussion and Dr Morris and I would
entirely agree that some 10 or 15 years
ago it was absolutely possible to
discuss the matter of gender of studies
in a very broad way not just in terms of
well biological implications but also in
literature in sociology in history this
was a conversation that we could have
now the trouble is that there is a side
of the question that cannot be expressed
anymore while by let's say 10-year
standards Kathleen stocks views were the
average ones but when it comes to the
question of platforming trans academics
yes absolutely we need to hear all the
voices now the thing is that if you walk
in any store well in two days from now
it will be pride month there will be
trans Flags every everywhere there is no
such thing as a problem regarding trans
visibility on the contrary all the
corporations are quite eager to make all
the money they can having all these
flags around so I'm all in for having an
intellectual debate that is not
something that is going to turn to the
advantage of either corporations or of
activists of either side look I think
you've picked up some really key points
so the corporation point in particular
what happened to Bud Light the beer and
the Dylan mulvania I am with you in that
I feel like trans people are being used
as pawns for corporate profit and gain
at some point Max I'll come to you to
speak on that but I also just want to
speak on the Free Speech side of things
because we've got to have these
platforms for debate and and Dr Marie
was just pointing out there 10 15 years
ago at universities you could do this I
did a an English literature degree that
had gender studies as part of it and we
would have talked about these kinds of
issues and we would have had
controversial voices speaking where have
we got to the 15 years later we can't
even have uh you know controversial
voices speaking at University
so I tell you what I'm a lecturer at
Oxford Brooks University up the hill and
in response to this event I've invited a
very prominent trans Professor to come
and speak uh give a public lecture at
Brooks which will be happening in a few
months time so I'm putting my you know
my actions where my words are in terms
of being a protester here today and
saying yes let's have controversial
speakers but let's not make them all uh
you know CIS women on one particular
side of the issue without hearing from
trans and non-binary people themselves
so I've invited Professor Stephen
Whittle to come and give a public
lecture he has been instrumental in the
drafting of the gender recognition Act
of 2004 the equalities Act of 2010 he is
one of the most preeminent experts in
this area why isn't he being invited to
debate at Oxford University why in this
private debating Club in a very elite
institution are we only hearing one
perspective Without Really any challenge
apart from those of us out here on the
street or those of us who were brave
enough to glue ourselves to the floor
and actually challenge some of these
very dodgy ideas and ideas that I think
most people wouldn't go along with let's
hear from one of the activists today Riz
I'm just one of you all trying to
protest uh this speech
as much as we have a right
right sir protest and I exercise those
rights I'm sure you won't agree with me
that her speech is dangerous is hateful
and it hurts trans people particular
transients
[Applause]
now I've seen rizz's sort of Manifesto
that they shared on on Twitter this
evening talking about why they did what
they did but the gluing the hand to the
floor trick we see it a lot from
eco-activists as well do you think Max
that that's the right way to get people
on site of this debate the viewers that
are watching this show
so I have to say I couldn't hear very
well
um over the microphone what was said by
that particular protester but what I
would say is that you know I was a part
of the protest today and there were you
know lots of people came with different
messages and most of us uh you know were
just trying to express our point of view
that we're either trans or non-binary
people or we're allies of trans and
non-binary people and yes people are
angry and sometimes people will speak in
ways that don't come across in the best
way but but there are lots of different
ways to make your point heard and
actually if you've been here today the
protest was very peaceful people were
having fun listening to music expressing
themselves and this idea that trans
people represent any kind of threat to
anybody could be totally you know
totally dismissed if you just came and
saw what the majority of protesters were
doing today it was a lovely lovely
atmosphere and so I suppose the one
thing we should thank Professor stock
for is giving us an opportunity as a
community a queer Community to come
together and celebrate the diversity of
our lives and our experiences well it
looks like we have found some sort of
peace or resolution in this debate so I
want to give the final word to Dr uh
Marie on this and just ask the question
on Free Speech uh do we have the right
to offend people
uh well I believe that all speech well
should be free but that the speech that
matters can also have consequences I
think that would be
yeah I mean that is an important Point
speech words they do have real world
impacts and effects do you think there
would be real world impacts from what
Kathleen stock was saying this evening
well I think I had the protesters
had they listened to what has been said
inside this room where I was instead of
well shouting and playing very loud
music they would have heard Kathleen
stock explaining what happens in the
fourth chapter the fifth chapter of her
book where she explains that we need
more non-binary spaces in terms of
policy making which does not contradict
our views about the necessity of clear
borders when it comes to safeguarding
but perhaps the non-binary would be
where we should aim to discuss and there
is something extremely binary in
thinking that because I would put on a
pair of trousers and behave in a
muscular manly way I would all of a
sudden
change sex and become a man or because
someone puts on a dress that person
would become a woman I think the binary
thinking is not where we think it is
look both of you thank you very much for
making time to speak to us this evening
for this uh what turned out to be a very
controversial speech but actually uh
you've motivated your sides very well
indeed thanks for making time
thank you and thank you Max for coming
well uncensored next tonight she has got
a lots more to say talk to the host of
former culture Minister Nadine Doris
takes on this morning and the Scofield
Saga look forward to that after the
break
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back now as a former culture
secretary herself Nadine Doris has a
thing or two to say about our biggest
broadcasters so you can imagine she
really has not been holding back about
this whole Philip Schofield Scandal
we've been watching unfold out of this
morning over the last week or so now
she's been calling this matter an abuse
of authority power and Trust she's
calling for a probe into complaints made
to ITV about Schofield and having
appeared herself as a guest on this
morning last year she says she's seen
firsthand how quite rude and
unprofessional the former presenter
behaves so who better to ask than the
lady herself the MP and uh talk to the
host needing Doris from talktv's very
own Friday night with Nadine uh they did
let's start very simply then should this
morning survive
oh
we've got some connection issues that
Indian if you're just one of my unmute
yourself because we've got a lot of
questions to ask you about broadcasting
about this what are you got us there
should this morning survive I didn't
actually mute myself but there you go
and so yeah I don't think it can survive
it's a story which isn't going anywhere
and it's
um it's one which is unfailing and
moving on a daily basis I think as I
think there have been illegal hurdles
when it first broke and I think those
hurdles have been overcome now so I
think it's not going away I think it's
one that's going to continue to go to
continue to grow and I just don't think
it can survive in its present format and
I think it was Diane Nelms who said it
that you know who's the original
um editor of the show but it's it really
just needs to go now it's also a stale
format actually it's been here for a
very long time with the same presenters
but there is so much which is
questionable about the entire culture
within this morning as a program and we
see this happen a lot in organizations
not just in television companies or
broadcasting organizations it happens in
organizations like the NHS and major
companies a culture grows
becomes toxic and it is protected by
those who are aware of the culture until
something gives and it's usually a
whistleblower or something happens to
kind of bully the lid off and that's
what's happened on this morning I
suppose you've worked on the program and
people have worked on the program over a
number of years and they all tell the
same story and so can it survive your
substantive question
possibly I don't know you know I don't
have a a crystal ball but I don't think
it should survive I think it needs to be
taken over by a safe Pair of Hands a
pair of hands at the public know that
they can trust because they've been lied
to there's been duplicity and an almost
a what they cover up and I think these
safe Pair of Hands while they spend time
thinking about what should be doing with
our midday
new spot on magazine spots should we
continue as it is so I should survive
maybe I mean I get your point about this
happens in other types of Industries you
cited they're the NHS it happens at
corporations toxicity investigations
that sort of thing but those are
fundamentally more substantial and
important things you know hospitals and
health care and companies this is just a
TV show isn't it I mean I'm not
detracting from what schofield's done I
think it's abhorrent I'm not attracting
for the experience of the boy at the
center of the law which we must always
keep in mind uh as well and and keep him
anonymous and the rest of it but it's
just a TV show is it not why why do we
care about this why are we talking about
this why does it matter to the public
honestly there's not that question
almost makes my blood boil because we
have in society men who use their
positions of authority and power and
trust and use those positions to
behave in a way which is inappropriate
and unacceptable I'm not going to quote
others within the same industry within
entertainment we know within the
entertainment industry there are serious
problems with individuals
but I think now we're at a point when
you're following on from me too and
other things that have happened I think
now we're at a point when I I when
Behavior which is being identified and
which has been covered up within a
culture which has protected that
behavior and in a culture which is toxic
and hugely inappropriate it has to be
called out it's not just a television
program it's it's a a situation where
not good things have happened and I'm
afraid that ITV both the executives the
editor and other people on that program
must have known and that's all because
of that because of that because of that
cover-up that I'm afraid they have to be
held accountable ITV is a public free to
a public service broadcaster it has
responsibilities both ethical and moral
and standards that it has to uphold just
because it's a television program
doesn't mean it can absolve itself of
those responsibilities we all have
responsibilities when we know that
inappropriate behavior has taken place
to call it out and to make sure that
it's dealt with in a way that sets an
example that others can see so that they
don't follow and they don't allow that
behavior to Fester within their
organization I think that's a strong
argument I think setting the right tone
the example I want to come back to you
on the public service broadcasting side
of it in the regulation Point as well
but I want to pick you up on your first
point there about you know my question
making your blood ball because your
answer in a sense makes my blood boil
because you said it was about me too or
it could be uh construed as having
something to do with that and this is a
man that is bullying and yes Phillip
Schofield is a man that is bullying in a
situation but I am always first to point
out when there is gender-based issues
going on toxicity and misogyny but in
this sense I think it is irrespective of
gender it is just an ego it's just
bullying it's toxicity and we see this
across many Industries and it's not
always uh men's fault there are women
bullies in this industry and I have
encountered them and I'm sure you have
too
I you know I knew to television so I
don't work in Industry as you do Rosanna
or for as long as you have so I haven't
come across that many people all I can
say is that the women I've come across
on talk have been absolutely fabulous
empowering women that I've loved working
with so I haven't encountered it myself
yet but you know if I did I would call
it out in the same way I would if I
encountered it in a month in the same
way I called it out in Phillip Schofield
now I'm afraid I haven't I haven't heard
women mentioned in the capacity of any
form of abuse or behavior that we've
seen amongst other men in the
entertainment industry going back over a
number of years now and you know we do
have to very carefully legally so I'm
not going to cite other other
individuals and other high-profile
stories that we all know about but the
point here is there is a man Philip
Schofield who has himself resigned from
they stepped away from his role and and
was further going to work with ITV in
another role until ITV removed him who
has behaved in a way which has been
highly inappropriate and that behavior
has been covered up by Executives at ITV
who absolutely must have known about it
because everybody else did and so I find
it impossible that they didn't the
editor of the program knew about it and
complaints were made and those
complaints were not act upon and if they
were at on they weren't acted upon an
away which got to the truth of the
situation and and exposed what was
happening
that you know every now and then
something will happen which which needs
to reset people's thoughts and behaviors
and their approach to to their work and
how we conduct ourselves whether it's in
television or it's in offices or the or
wherever it is and I'm afraid this is
one of those instances it is one of
those instances I'm in agreement with
you there um we must obviously State the
executives have denied a lot of the
allegations levied against them a lot of
these details are still ongoing and
emerging and we have of course had
statement upon statement for my TV uh
denying this as we've had a statement
from Schofield as well but some some
astonishing Revelations just in the last
two hours uh Nadine this one about the
payoff the executives allegedly knew
this is a an article in the mail online
this evening uh Executives knew about a
payoff that was given to the young man
as he was moved over to loose women and
the other
um a bit of detail that we've got here
are more pictures of the anonymized
young man that I want to come to you
specifically I'll give you a former
secretary is that the executives are
going to be hauled up before a committee
a government committee next week to talk
about this as part of the sort of Media
bill review that's ongoing so talk to us
a little bit about why you think the
government should be intervening here
because a lot of Americans look at
British TV and say government intervenes
too much
well because ITB is a public service
broadcaster and therefore it will play a
huge part in the media bill which is a
bill I launched and introduced when I
was Secretary of State
um the media built impacts ITV in a way
which is
um which is
favorable to Public Service broadcasters
so I'm afraid it's absolutely right and
proper that they should go before the um
dcms cut slack committee absolutely
right that they should do not think that
there's a some of the public will see a
bit of an irony in seeing uh members of
Westminster debating sleaze and
corruption in the TV industry oh yeah I
get that I totally get that yeah yeah
I'd be a reason why I'm standing down
the next election yes you have stood
down it is worth restating and of course
you're part of the talk TV family now um
just before we let you you get on with
your evening a water family is the
producers the same IAS it is a family uh
let's just uh none of the allegations
levied I will say that we've talked
about relate to this network at all
um but let me just ask you a little bit
about your experience when you're on
this morning what was it like and what
kind of impression did you get of Holly
as well
so I found Holly absolutely lovely and
she was she was delight and I can't
remember how many times I've been on the
program but it was the last time I was
on when Holly wasn't there and um
someone was starting to Joe was standing
in for Holly and what I saw actually
made me so you can see the picture on
the screen at the moment
um gosh I can't remember the other beats
that presented it her name's Joseph
Josie Gibson she was on I think it was
love Island and while she was holding
that very script in her hand and uh the
camera was on me he landed over and
started jabbing at that script like this
in her hand
possibly of seeing what he was pointing
to his face was like thunder it was
incredibly aggressive and she just sat
there holding the script as he was
bashing it with his hands while the
camera was on me and it actually made me
feel incredibly uncomfortable and yeah I
mean that that was it was he was
unpleasant you know and I know I've
heard from so many people that he you
know didn't know the names of anybody on
the production teams even people who'd
worked there for years many years with
him that he was that he was rude I mean
I think Eamonn Holmes has given his own
um account of what working with Philip
Schofield is like and obviously he's far
more authoritative than I am I only saw
him you know for the occasions and I was
sat in front of him but I always found
Holly an absolute Delight
what I'm disappointed about is as the
story has moved on it is actually
unbelievable that Holly did not know
what was taking place and although I
found it I find her Delight passing on a
personal level I think there must is
some degree of that cover-up
encompassing Holly as well and I think
that's incredibly disappointing because
I think she's an amazing role model for
women particularly women who want to
work in the television industry her
career has been just impeccable and to
this point I'm afraid a bit like you
know in the morning show when
um the the host took down other people
with him I think Phillip Schofield might
be people he's been working with on this
morning which I think is sad because I
think the holidays are professional and
you know which I've always found her
lovely
up but it could be the case that she
didn't know what was going on because
everybody else did he wasn't as close to
Phillip Schofield we will be talking a
lot more about this toxicity nests and
what people knew but Nadine it's up to
you me everyone else in Industry
obviously to continue to be nice to not
be bullied uh and to engender a better
work environment Nadine Doris it's been
great having your insights on this this
evening
cheers Nadine thank you uncensored next
tonight it isn't just ITV that has seen
accusations of a toxic environment
Channel 4 and the BBC have also
experienced bumps in the road recently
so is the TV industry institutionally
toxic or have we all become snowflakes
we'll be debating that next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's up
this is talk TV
foreign
[Music]
this evening talking all things tele on
your Telly itv's Philip Schofield of
course not the only TV presenter to face
accusations of abusing his position of
power this week it has also been
reported that channel 4 have parted ways
with escape to the Shadows dick and
Angel insiders claiming the pet were
rude and bullying towards production
staff the leaked audio of one encounter
they had pretty damning take a listen
just tell me that and then
remind me actually now this is me angry
I just wanted to know where you both
were okay now do not work in this
Chateau and then pose dark weird
pictures that I find quite insulting and
do not smirk yikes oh my goodness that
was my first time hearing that something
isn't it that abusive rant happened in
2021 supposedly concerning a delay of
all things and Angela's in Angel's
schedule rather and a producer's
Instagram post shock horror can you
believe it and that was worthy of that
type of rant now of course even the BBC
have had to deal with fallouts of their
own most recently Greg Wallace quitting
his show inside the factory for
allegedly offending women on set so is
TV institutionally toxic debating this
we've got the show biz on Sunday editor
at the sun on Sunday Hannah hope in the
studio with us lovely to see Hannah and
TV Executives commissioning editor
Channel 4 Stephen D Wright also joining
us uh down the line
um and Stephen actually just there uh
you I hope you heard that clip just now
of angel from Escape The Shadow but uh
does that give you the sense that TV is
institutionally toxic given your
experience
yes absolutely and that kind of
conversation that kind of swearing and
everything is completely normal I mean
you you know present a shout at staff
but bossy staff everybody shout out to
each other TV is a toxic industry
absolutely it is a toxic industry but
should it be fixed is it is it necessary
to have toxic people to make good
television television
there's a million pound question it
really is and I mean these people don't
start off as monsters they become the
way TV enables them you know this is the
problem with TV you you start to
um put people presenters mainly on a
pedestal and then you have a kind of you
know hundreds of acolytes running around
saying yes to their every whim it
doesn't take long for somebody to go a
bit mad with power and and all that sort
of narcissism and glory and add Fame
into the mix and suddenly you've got a
very sort of explosive uh sort of thing
and of course people in TV behind the
scenes are constantly trying to keep
that toxicity from from going on to
screen you know this is why the whole
this morning Scandal is so shocking to
to the viewers because it all seems to
be lovely and friendly and warm and
sunny but in actual fact it's you know
Riven you know it's a a Viper's Nest
basically I should catch myself there I
laughed when you said uh turning into
monsters because I was suddenly very
self-aware that I'm sat here as a
present from Piers Morgan's show and I'd
like to clap I'm not a monster and I do
have feelings and I do understand the
severity of the issue that we're talking
about here perform attacked on Twitter
for this I'd like to think I'm not a
monster I'm going to come to Holly and
the Stu sorry brother to Hannah in the
studio because you were nodding along
vigorously there uh when you were
hearing about sort of the toxicity of
presenters and their acolytes Stephen
made some very good points presenters
are celebration in such a way with
inflated Egos and paychecks they almost
do become monsters I mean I've seen many
a diva struck behind the scenes on
several different channels but in the
age of social media and camera phones
there is no real behind the scenes
anymore and cancel culture is Rife as we
are very well well aware on this channel
so I do wonder if if that behavior is
becoming less and less acceptable could
you have uh seen that type of behavior
emerging from the past from what you
knew of Schofield obviously we've heard
allegations that there were whisperings
of what was going on the industry for a
very long time before it suddenly
exploded but could you assess monsters
when you're doing your job as a Showbiz
editor a reporter can you look at people
and think yeah that person's a
narcissistic bully you do see people
turn it on for the camera don't you you
do see people who are very Charming on
camera and then behind the scenes or on
a red carpet they may storm down and not
make any eye contact and you think oh
they're not as friendly as they are on
telly I mean certainly with Phil and
Holly what's very disappointing is the
viewers were sold this dream as it were
this friendly TV mum and dad coming into
their living rooms day in day out and I
think the viewer had put their trust in
this couple onto and thought they were
their friends their family and actually
it doesn't seem that that's the case at
all and they're actually quite fake so
it is the sort of crushing reality of
what is happening here The Lies We were
sold coming back to uh to Stephen and
you know we've got this title on the
screen saying it's British Telly turning
toxic but I think there might be some of
our audience um over the age of say 40
50 60. he'll say it's been toxic for
some time there's been scandals rolling
out from the 80s and 90s for volatile I
mean dare we talk about Savile of course
but also plenty of breakfast TV shows
that have been shown to be toxic and
nothing's changed
well I mean it exactly that I mean if if
anything it has it's cleaned up a little
bit but the problem is the same sort of
cocktail of uh Beauty narcissism fame
money Glory whatever added to that a lot
of pressure I mean this is the problems
that from the TV industry TV is made
under extreme pressure people are
working very long hours sometimes you
know it's just anger and stress it's not
nastiness but it's all there all the
time and there's so much stress there's
so much kind of riding on it that people
can lose it very quickly so it's always
been a horrendous I mean I I tell
everybody don't come into TV it's a
horrible industry to working you have to
really love it because you will be sort
of chewed up and spat out but um you
know it's not necessarily getting more
toxic it's just we're getting more sort
of reactive to uh presenters having
strops we never used to be like this 20
30 years ago people didn't bother about
people being a bit nasty behind the
camera you know sex scandals yes but
sort of angry bullying seeing that sort
of thing that wasn't really
um important but now you know TV's under
the microscope particularly by the press
and and uh you know Hannah's completely
right you know there is no behind the
scenes now because of camera phone
because of Twitter and things like that
people can can can expose a scandal
within the old days they'd all have been
sort of there would be no way to expose
a scandal you know unless you were a
journalist but now everyone can be a
journalist in a minute and so therefore
if somebody does have a massive drop it
can be on online in seconds and so you
know we're more hyper Vigilant but it's
you know TV is still the same toxic
industry it's it's not more toxic it
just is toxic I've inclined to go
through there I too Stephen tell young
people who approach me and asked how
they can do my job to think about
something else maybe Hannah uh coming to
you because you were nodding on there uh
let's just talk about the way next for
ITV obviously a ton of Revelations this
evening the latest of which Scofield
being dropped from his role at the
prince's trust in terms of where ITV
goes where the show goes where Holly
goes what's your addiction so we do know
that there have been huge crisis talks
behind the scenes ITV a standing firm
they're saying that Holly is you know
going to be back on the sofas on Monday
and Holly has said behind the scenes to
people around her that she doesn't feel
that she wants to step down or anything
the problem is is the public opinion is
really swaying now I think they've lost
a lot of trust in this morning they've
lost their biggest Advertiser Arnold
Clark and I think that people are kind
of wanting to see a head roll and
wondering if if one of the main
directors of ITV Kevin ligo May step
away even Martin Frizzell the editor of
this morning and the problem with Holly
even though she says that she didn't
know anything is that she is very
reminiscent of Philip she was part of a
TV Duo for over a decade so how this
morning goes forward uh remains to be
seen yeah is Stephen coming back to you
will that mollify uh people do you think
if some Executives leave the show or
leave the organization
I think that possibly I mean the show
should take a break really that's the
easiest way to do it um you know it
should just come off air for a month or
something and then Rebrand itself and
come back on air and boom we're off
again
um Holly is a difficult one she's she's
queen of TV she doesn't necessarily have
to be on this morning
um but the ITV needs to do something
because this every day this drip drip
drip is getting worse you know I
personally think the show can survive it
because the the content of the show is
still good and it works with with
whatever presenters are on it you know I
still miss Eamonn and Ruth for example
but um it's it's so I don't think it's
it's you know let's uh sort of you know
throw the baby out with the bath water
it's it's doable and Holly can can
easily sort of just vanish for a little
bit and come back on another show and
everyone will forgive her I think
so yeah I'm still sort of fan I'm with
you though it seems to be this drip drip
who knows what tomorrow will bring uh
Stephen uh Hannah it's been so good to
get your insights this evening thanks so
much
well I'm standing next tonight the pack
will be with me to discuss the Schofield
drama and whether the honors list here
in this country should give more
knighthoods to Northerners we're going
to be debating all of those stories next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
coming up on the talk claims Phillip
schofield's Lover from this morning was
paid off by ITV as a former presenter
says there was a total cover-up
transgender activists tried to disrupt a
controversial speech on gender by gluing
themselves to the floor and supermarkets
and locking up food to stop thefts as
the cost of living crisis worsens that's
all at nine o'clock
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored I'm sitting
here for peers this evening I want to
remind you that this show has been
shortlisted for an NTA award we love
these Awards in the TV industry this is
Piers Morgan's interview he did with
Ronaldo take a photo of your screw with
the camera now that QR code will take
you through to the shortlist so you can
land your vote to get Piers another gong
for his dressing room he would really
appreciate it it's like a charity appeal
joined in the studio right now where
I'll pack political journalist Ava
Santina talk TV contributor Paula Brown
Adrian and talk TV presenter Richard
Tice great to have you all in with us
and it's a lot of focus on telly and I
have a bit of an issue with discs I
think do the viewers care that much but
I think they sort of do find this
morning that interesting don't they Ava
I know you do you've been following it
closely well I just think it's sort of
bizarre because it's kind of like we've
grown up with these two people you know
they've just been an omnipresent for so
in your life and the whole thing is just
kind of falling apart before our eyes so
it's shocking you know the revelations
this evening that they're going to be
hauled up in front of the dcms committee
next week which means that MPS will be
able to question uh the ITV bosses about
what went on I mean that's really going
to be essential viewing I'll be glued
into that yeah Nadine Doris was talking
to us about you know the severity of
that what it means with regard to the
media Bill uh Paula there is a legal
aspect to this a regulatory element too
but are you just generally shocked by
the revelations I'm not shocked by the
revelations what I'm shocked at actually
is the focus and attention that this is
getting and I and I have to say I'm
going to throw the captain on the
pigeons here and ask the question if
this wasn't about a homosexual
relationship would we be hearing about
this because you know we're allowed to
be gay on TV but what we're not allowed
is to be gay and have sex now now big
statement of course we have lots of
powerful men in TV on films in the music
industry etc etc
having Affairs we have lots of women
having an Affairs but that doesn't make
the news and actually even in politics
and what actually we're told is it's
none of our business it's their personal
life as long as they're doing their job
properly let them get on with it now I
don't happen to agree with that I think
there should be an investigation I think
things should be looked into we've got a
vulnerable person here we've got
somebody in power
potentially somebody taken advantage of
I'm yeah and I think that's why we're
talking about it it's it's an obvious
abuse of power I mean you're entitled to
that view on things I'm gonna disagree
with you but you know from what informed
opinion I don't really have one Richard
I mean abuse of power fairly obvious to
be honest until 10 days ago I didn't
have an opinion because I didn't grow up
with Phil and Holly who's got time to
watch daytime TV For Heaven's Sake but
actually I'm not sure it's about the the
gay element to it I think it's the abuse
of power from what I've learned I think
it's it's it's just the the age
difference the deceit the Perpetual line
I come from the corporate world how on
Earth is the chief executive of ITV
frankly still in that job I've done
non-execs the null execs must be tearing
their hair out I think I'll be surprised
if she's still in the job by the time
they get to the committee next week yeah
I think that interesting one who's whose
head is going to roll on this further
then we have look we've got a
uh our viewers back home this is rock
band Royal Blood uh talking to the crowd
at Radio one's big weekend calling them
pathetic take a look
well uh I guess I should introduce
ourselves seeing as uh no one actually
knows who we are we're called royal
blood and this is uh rock music who
likes rock music
nine people brilliant we're having to
clap ourselves because that was so
pathetic well done
it's not right
so of course Ava you shared this this
morning on Twitter and I saw it off your
off your Twitter I mean it is pretty
pathetic it's a bit of a posh tantrum
yeah and it's just cringe what what I
don't understand is radio one made this
band like they made them popular they
put them in the top 40. this band has a
quarter of a billion players on most of
it's their songs on Spotify and now
they're getting on stage and sort of
like playing this kind of weird victim
game as if they're not appealing to like
the masses they're kind of eclectic and
two you know too cool to me like you
know what they're probably going to
watch this back and they're going to go
who's she in her pink dress to like rock
music that's the kind of impression
they're giving
[Laughter]
the two of you do you know Royal Blood
Richard not a fan Paula I've got to be
honest never heard of them exactly after
that hopeless sort of concert and lack
of motivation come on listen they're
rockers they're all about the shock
Factor I'm saying good luck to them I'm
surely I'm really interested in them now
I want to see them they want to be in
front of an audience who wants to see
them today
as well I'm not being funny but it's not
exactly like we've gone back to punk or
something interesting this is a couple
of Posh boys who are up on stage of you
know in like the most social background
is not relevant to this it is relevant
music it's about no it is
no do you know what they're doing
they're cosplaying that's what they're
doing they're pretending to be like from
the punk era from like proper like
they're into rock or something they're
not they're privileged white men who've
grown up and are now expecting to be
applauded so they're being fake a bit
like Phil perhaps
bring it back
kind of a being loyal to your fans or
not being very gracious on stage is it
that social backgrounds
yes and if the fans come with you they
come with you and you can't force
audiences to like you the way that you
want them to like you they're either
going to like what you're bringing to
the table or not let's finish on this
statistic because it got us all laughing
in The Newsroom earlier nearly one in
eight men 35 and under admit to Bringing
protection to a funeral we're talking
condoms here this was a survey of 18 to
35 year olds in the US I mean what did
you think when you heard this over it's
just just say I mean like what what are
men like what is that like a question
what is that not guilty as charged no
way absolutely absurd so what I really
wanted to know when I saw this research
was number one did we find out how many
of them used the condoms oh yeah and
number two did we find out if they
thought that the person in the coffin
was dead or not oh goodness sorry guys
way too much information I think it's
more getting lucky in the congregation
like it's been a wild ride that is it
from all of us here in the studio
whatever you're up to tonight make sure
it is uncensored good night
thank you
[Music]
foreign